my job it was simple simpler than cuses
cus Knew Too Much I knew nothing I just
knew you know rudiments of boxing I knew
what it took to be a fighter and and how
to execute it the steps of executing it
so I took those steps the the the rest
of it you get blurred by those other
things I wasn't blurred by those other
things I it was it was just get him in
the
gym make him mentally stronger make him
face things and teach them how to slip
punches and and create holes and fill
those freaking holes with devastating
punches this is a cuss and what are you
going to do I'm going to teach him to
fill holes and fill them with punches
with bad intentions yeah and and that
became the Monica yeah and then Tyson
would say that I'm throwing punches with
bad intentions yes you are and um you
know how do you make it mentally tougher
so that part of the job the you said the
don't get a bloody nose but but the part
of the job will makes him mentally
tougher how do you do that most
important part of the job to make a face
things yeah make him face where he's
lying to himself where he's submitting
what if we start this conversation with
submission yeah submit less yeah submit
less submit less every day submit less
cuz only come to gym once in a while and
if I had him spawn he would come because
that was his that was his project that
was the heavyweight now he came you know
put life in cus cuz had life he he was
losing a little life but that made the
light bulb bright again it did and it
was great to see I felt proud of that I
felt connected to that and that's why
when when when it all went bad and cus
took the side that the only side he
could sake the side of the next
heavyweight champ of the world but he
but he left me his partner the young
master
and of the second time I get betrayed
and I'm
like
for a while I thought everything CU
taught me said to me was a liar I didn't
want to be any part of it anymore until
I got a little more mature and I got a
little past
that where I was able to
understand I was able to
understand
that just because somebody that you
perceived as great in every area is you
find to be weak in certain
areas does it
mean that they can't still be what they
want to
you it's it's something
that it's something that can be
understood or
forgiven it's hard it's hard to get to
that place to forgive somebody in that
kind of way that I felt betrayed because
CU told me the most important one thing
was loyalty cuz told me he loved me
because I was loyal cuz cuz told people
that the reason that he went to court
was because I didn't give up anybody
even though it meant put me in the risk
of going to jail for 10 years and he and
cuz felt that he admired those traits
and so I assumed that he he would show
the same traits and he took a
deal he took a deal he took a deal he he
he signed the papers that those that
those so-called feds of M signed you
know he he he took a deal to to you
know to to have the future heavyweight
championsship turned out uh and and to
let me you know to let me go to sign the
deal to to let me take you know take the
weight for people who don't
know uh Mike was inappropriate with the
young girl and you pulled the gun on
him I don't know if there's deeper
things to say about that situation no
but why do you think cus made the
decision to cut you off from both Mike
Tyson and from C Cato like to break that
when he valued loyalty so much I served
my purpose I got him to the way he
needed to
get um brought life back in the gym if I
wasn't in the gym at that particular
time Tyson never would have been in the
gym there would have been no gymm to
bring them to mhm when they called up
and made that phone call to bring them
to the gym there would have been no
activity there would have been no boxing
program there would have been you know
no trainer training them 247 the way I
was where C wasn't capable of doing that
at that Bo in his life yeah but then
again it's not poor Teddy I get the
benefit of a career I get the benefit of
knowledge I get the benefit of a life I
get the benefit of learning of of
becoming hopefully a better person
um I got the benefit of being betrayed
again um but that's a hell of a
statement right there I don't know what
the benefit of that
is you can learn to forgive
weakness you
know when you realize
how how easy it is to be
weak and and when you realize that
somebody asked me how did you get to the
point where you you could forgive right
it's a pretty good question pretty
simple pretty basic pretty important
right and I didn't I didn't understand I
understood but I did understand
immediately for
me I said how can I not forgive
somebody it becomes easier to learn how
to
forgive when you're still trying to
forgive yourself
when you're still in the process of
trying to forgive yourself for all your
own inherent
weaknesses and betrayals of people like
my
father in different ways that we forget
very easily because it's
handy and it's a way of
surviving it's a lot easier to to figure
it out rationalize it to to to to find
forgiveness
when you realize that you still haven't
figured out completely how to forgive
yourself I'm still trying to figure that
out and
um so that helped me figure out how to
forgive
cus because to figure out how to forgive
me I had to understood why I did these
things where the where the weaknesses
came from where the selfishness came
from where the convenience came from
that they really
existed but they didn't exist for
malice they existed for me not being
prepared to understand that I could be
stronger to want to be stronger and then
I looked at CU he wanted to be stronger
but he got to a point in life where he
had been strong for a lot of his life he
was strong with me he was strong with a
lot of things in his life and does
everyone deserve a pass in
life
where he got he got to a place where
everything was in one basket the basket
of boxing he once told me that he never
got married because it would be on it
would been selfish to a woman to have
gotten married when his whole life was
boxing that he couldn't give to a kid he
couldn't give to her he could and and
then I thought about it he had no money
really and Jim Jacob and Bill cadon took
care of the bills so he didn't really
need money that way
but the one what was the payoff for that
kind of life that kind of commitment
that kind of
sacrifice really what was the payoff the
payoff was to have
Champions to have a champion that would
keep your name
alive you know that word legacy like
what does it mean sometimes it's it's
just a word sometimes it's is more than
a word it it's it's it's a
reprieve it's a pension plan is is being
given a pension on your way out for the
rest of your life for for your life
wherever you're going you're going to
wherever you're going for eternity um it
it's it's it's the only thing that you
take with you is what you left behind
and for cus it was all about leaving
behind a mark a Mark that of champion
yeah it was attached to Ego we all have
it yeah it was attached to some
selfishness and all but yeah it was also
attached to wanting to leave something
great behind yeah to know that you were
part of it that you existed for a reason
that that that you sacrificed for a
reason and all that freaking pain I
brought my
father I was searching for something
yeah I made it into a righteous search I
made it into I did and I made it into it
was okay because it was righteous and I
but it still did
damage it still did damage it still hurt
people it still betrayed my father's
trust
and cuz betrayed mine but he didn't do
it
maliciously he he did it out of
again
my father came home this is how I'm
going to connect it my father came home
from from work one night 12:00 and I was
waiting up and like I said I was over 9
10 years old and he got mad at me he
goes go to bed what are you doing up I
said I'm waiting for you waiting for you
and
um he said well go to bed I said no I I
I what were you doing he said I was at
the hospital you were there why were you
there so late
you
know he answered me he he said there was
a patient there was a sick patient I
said oh he must be better now because
you're his doctor you know because my
father could fix
anything and my father nothing got in
the way of the truth nothing nothing
even blown his son's
bubble matter of factly he said to
me uh no he's not going to get better
he's going to die
and
um so as a 9-year-old kid you know
you're a kid you're selfish you know not
in a bad way but you know you want what
you and I said
um I said two things first I said how
how you're his
doctor how it can't be and then I said I
I just said it almost angry then why
were you there like you should have been
here with me yeah and you know what he
said to me CU you don't give up on
life go to
bed and don't give up on life and that's
I finally connected the dots this idiot
that didn't graduate high
school I finally connected to dots I was
asking cut to give up on
life you don't you don't give up on life
you don't give up up on aspirations of
life life is all forms of life doesn't
have to be a physical form of it it's
life it's having a reason to be
alive it's having a reason to have
tomorrow and and C's only reason to have
tomorrow was to have another heavyweight
champ and Teddy Atlas even though we
were together all those years and we
were partners and we trained together
and we would we would you know the only
thing we didn't do was what they did in
the Indian movies where where they cut
the finger and they became Blood
Brothers that's that's the only thing we
didn't do and I felt like we did that
yeah without cutting
and and now here we are and he freaking
betrayed me just and and um and then all
of a sudden I connected to D I was
like he didn't betray me in the in that
cold
sense he didn't give up on life
life